we had brandon shaw bond which was great
it was great talking to brandon and he
loves you
brendan also who yeah brendan he's used
to it he's just a brand what did i say
brandon brandon yeah well that's your
thing you know like people do it all the
time
brendan schaub you'll call him brandon i
call him brianna
you a very uh athletic individual
high school
he brought it up on he says i told one
of the guys yeah you know he was talking
about one of the guys you know what it
was but we're we're still friends
i thought brendan was a great guest i
think he's funny it is what it is we
played dodgeball and he can't throw a
ball i said it i said it out loud i saw
it
well you were telling the story about
how he blew out a couple of hamstrings i
don't know if you want to throw that
switch well it's common it was on the
podcast you know i'm begging him to warm
up before he sprints 100 yards since he
hasn't done it in 10 years and
he kind of went now
to you
he give me that right in the face yeah
i'm good the whole hands in the face
because because the thing about getting
older you realize the laws of physics
the laws of the universe apply to you
when you're young and you're like well
you know i don't you i have this joke
about the fact that when you're young
you actually do believe you're one of
god's favorites right you do you're
invincible tragedy and loss it's so sad
over there but i'm just going to keep it
yeah
and that's why you do crazy things like
parkour because gravity you know but
nobody in their 40s picks up parkour
because you realize well
the god there is no there are no
favorites yeah you know and it's it's
it's but there are though there are a
few favors you my friend
[Music]
are you 50 yet how old are you 55. what
have you learned about here are you
really get out of here that right no
[ __ ] what have you learned about
strategic skills good for you stretch
stretching because brendan schaub did it
55. take your lesson forward i i do i
people laugh but i actually do yoga
every day but
not long really yeah but
my philosophy is moderation and i think
uh what i'll do is if i'm gonna lift
weights
i'll do 20 minutes but it's intense i'll
do maybe 15 minutes of yoga not this
hour and a half stuff and i think
consistency and then just learning not
to learning how to eat not getting crazy
not turning into a religion let's enjoy
our life please and and just at the end
of the day moderation golden mean
people get too crazy i'm i'm carnivore
i'm keto i i just i'm sorry it's it's
too much it's i don't subscribe to that
well i got caught last week i was i was
with the girl i was in the bathroom
because i know we're about to hook up i
was i got caught stretching in the back
she was like why are you counting in
there i was like i was like just shut
just mind your business like don't worry
about it you're stretching before 400 i
don't want to pull something during
you know i mean
you did a bit we went to his comedy show
about how like you oh yeah sex in your
20s there's a lot of different secrets
about 40s and i i did a bit where i'm
like you know when you were younger you
could pick the girl up go on the dresser
and she would throw everything off the
dresser i go that's hot at 20. at 40
your whole life is on that dresser
there's antiques if a girl does that i'm
like time out that's my humidifier
picture it's a picture of my mother what
are you telling you
yeah adam are you doing it's my whole
mother so he's a dresser you also don't
care i mean after a while it's like all
right we've done all this
yeah a little connection and we'll move
on
i got 15 minutes how did the stretching
work out for you though it's dude i'm
not because you know i'm i'm 44 years
old it worked i'm just saying like when
i hook up now by the little side thing i
have water a banana i don't know
patrick i swear to god when you're
getting your four you guys when you're
when you're in your 40s i don't care
like what do you do make fun of me i
don't care anymore if i was 20 i'd be
like
now it's whatever bro i'm stretching i
have to the whole yoga thing i have by
the way that that visual is a little
concerning yeah i'm just thinking okay
let me do the couple stretches
babe you ready banana on the no no the
the
i heard somebody say they were talking
about the red queen phenomenon that idea
that you know you have to run as fast as
you can just to stay in place
right and it's a term that they use
sometimes which comes from alice in
wonderland and uh
i think when you get to a certain age
that's exactly what happens you start to
accept part of what wisdom might be is
coming to terms with your own
limitations coming to terms with the
fact that no matter what you do you are
a limited creature and you are you are
no matter what you do you're probably
gonna you're not gonna look as good next
year you're not gonna be as strong next
year no matter what there just comes a
time when you've got to accept the
inevitable decline of the body but i
think with that comes um hidden gifts
hidden such as what acceptance uh
understanding wisdom um letting go of
those kinds of things that you probably
shouldn't have been holding on to in the
first place and and and making room
in your mind for
other
other efforts and other understandings
how much of that you think is wisdom how
much of that is the fact that your
testosterone level is just lower
you know this is this becomes a question
between biology and spirituality right
like it's so funny as as your biology
yeah
you somehow you get so serious
exactly
why why am i putting god down
exactly what happened you kids keep
having sex dancing
because i'm afraid i'm gonna get to
heaven and god's gonna have my entire
life on one piece of paper like my dad
did with my report card by the way think
about it if they ran the testosterone
you know levels of people go to church
what that would look like like
attendance wise probably very low
cracking data yeah that's what i'm
saying like it's like great question
dude if i find a church with
high testosterone level attendees think
about that church oh my god i mean
they're sinning every other
that's the church you want to go hell
yeah i want to be at that church you
could draw a correlation i guarantee to
antibiotics to things that took care of
syphilis and other things where sex
didn't cost you your life
and
and and also even the pill and all these
things that kind of liberate back in the
day dude sex was a very risky enterprise
you could get some crazy disease you
could get pregnant and be banished from
society and that so i think you're right
i mean a lot of things are kind of like
god kind of died with antibiotics and
birth control so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]